let's give a GSB welcome to Elinor Lally
Thank You thanks thank you
thank you so how are you good
I'll be outside after this to take your
car orders we got some great vehicles
for you first of all it's really neat to
be back in the MBA program and what I
thought I'd do is you're still studying
case studies right do a lot of that and
they describe the situation and give you
lots and lots of data then you're
supposed to think or reflect on what you
would do so I thought a way to introduce
our conversation they was is let's do a
case study on Ford okay and you get to
be me okay because I'm looking for a few
more good ideas I'm going to get it here
today okay so it's 2006 its September
I'm the chief executive officer at
Boeing Commercial Airplanes I'm looking
forward to creating one more Boeing
airplane to replace maybe the 737 eighty
percent of all of the seats are flying
worldwide or Boeing airplanes feeling
really good about Boeing feeling really
good about our contribution to safe and
efficient transportation and I get a
phone call from Bill Ford I'm going Bill
Ford of like the Ford Motor Company the
great-grandson of Henry Ford that's the
one and he said we're in really tough
shape and I would really like your help
and we do consider coming to Ford so I
started doing my due diligence and at
the end of the day I was being asked to
serve a second American and global icon
and I just couldn't I just couldn't turn
that opportunity down so I walk into the
office in the world headquarters so the
Ford Motor Company the 12th floor
and I look out the window and here's the
Rouge plant and here's where Henry Ford
created the moving assembly line this is
where mr. Toyoda
of Toyota came to visit to learn how to
make cars and how to continuously
improve the quality and productivity and
here was the entire plant at the time he
was a hundred percent vertically
integrated the most efficient operation
in the world and I'm reviewing the
situation and here's the situation
I check with our finance people and they
give me the the great news that we are
projected to lose 17 billion dollars in
2006 you can run out of money really
fast
at 17 billion dollars a year
I also review the situation about what
Ford has become and Ford has now become
a house of brands and remember I left
Boeing to come to Ford and Ford was
Aston Martin
it was Jaguar it was Land Rover it was
Volvo had a significant relationship
with Mazda and so Ford was as house of
brands and it also happened to have Ford
and Mercury and Lincoln brands also also
Henry Ford set up for it all around the
world so that he could participate in
the economy not only provide great cars
and trucks but also be part of the
economic fabric of all the countries in
which Ford operated but Ford had become
very regionalised and none of the Fords
talked to each other around the world
there was no synergy and we were
competing with the best global companies
in the world and we had no scale and no
integration of all the intellectual
capability around the world also in the
United States we had labor agreements
with the unions and our cost structure
where we really couldn't make cars in
the United States and make them probably
so we stopped doing that and the ones
that we did make were pretty marginal
and we focused on bigger SUVs and trucks
so if you wanted to if you wanted to you
know living in 150 and pull your house
behind a simultaneously you could get
the best truck in the world from Ford
but we didn't have a full family of
vehicles in the United States also we
had never really had made a commitment
to be invest in class with the
competition so we were kind of
competitive on quality and fuel
efficiency and safety and really smart
design and but we weren't really
best-in-class in addition we were
unprofitable in every one of those
brands and in every model we were losing
money thinking back I wonder why I did
cup
and we are running out of cash really
fast so that's the situation I've got a
card and I have a pencil so should
please shout out what you would do you
thought this is going to be a free lunch
okay
now with that situation this is Stanford
the MBA program we got engineers we got
business we got the smartest people in
the world right here right okay what
would you do okay just shout it out okay
now I'm going to take notes because I
got a feeling that this is going to work
out really well okay fantastic
probably overcapacity
good good
standardize the platforms Wow good what
would you do about that
very good okay what else
Wow what do you mean by that fantastic
fantastic okay what else
that was not part of the plan although
we that's what happened because we're a
real pain right now
Wow
maybe all around the world really
overall your designer process hmm yeah
absolutely and the production yeah
maybe do it together Oh what do you
think the customers really want focus on
quality safety seamlessly connected to
the Internet
hands on the wheel eyes on the road
Bluetooth activated sync my fort
oh man I found the next management team
right here what else really I mean you
can't compete on a global scale by
operating regionally that's really
something whoa whoa are your reliance on
incentives
I personally have this philosophy if I
if I think anybody's from China I give
him a hug
we're gonna talk about this a little bit
but the China market now as you know is
bigger than the United States it's just
a fabulous opportunity they love the
Ford brand we're expanding as fast as we
can
now why would you do that
what tweener is that's a new business
school expression it was it with what
really we'll talk about this some more
and again this allows you to ask the
questions that you want to ask to
because all of these were clearly part
of the plan what would you do about
financing then I'll run out of money
right so when you do a transformation
like this the most important thing is
when you have a plan but to do you have
the financing in place because if you
run out of money during the during the
transformation that doesn't work out so
get a home improvement loan got it okay
what else because they're so cool yeah
but better have a cost structure here so
you can make them here too okay I did
that on the first day back to got a
preserved cache oh you got to be the
laser focus okay this is fantastic and
this is what we did and thanks for
inviting me
and I would propose to you that
everything you said is about leadership
because that's what your class is about
today
everything that you said is about
leadership because every one of those is
a courageous decision it's going to come
from having a point of view about the
future and having your conviction that
you're going to have a comprehensive
plan to implement that compelling vision
now just one last question what would
you use what would you have used for
your vision in this situation something
think of like what would you have
rallied everybody around because you
clearly are where you are but you're
going to a different place you just
described this different place what
would you what would you do about that
compelling vision how would you describe
what your new Ford's going to be like
what do you think that's important oh
man I don't know what I can wait till
after this to meet you okay that's
absolutely incredible and that's exactly
what we did and when you walk into that
same office today where I walked in four
and a half years ago the the entire wall
is filled up with Henry Ford's vision
for the Ford Motor Company that he laid
out on January 24th of 1925 in The
Saturday Evening Post and you can google
it and find it it's like fantastic and
it says opening the highways to all
mankind that's what Henry Ford was about
he wanted to make traveling on the
highways affordable and available for
all of us and at the time the only
people that had a car where we were
wealthy you couldn't afford a car so he
describes in this vision how it would
have to be big and scale big and scope
to get the economies of scale it would
have to be a complete family of vehicles
they have to be best in class and safety
and efficiency and have to contribute to
making life more pleasant more useful if
everybody would have to participate
at the time January 24 1925 he's at the
top of his game he has 56 percent market
share worldwide every country around the
world wants Henry to come and set up his
operations he's widely successful by any
measure and at the end of this
advertisement for his vision it says
that it's not about what Ford has done
up through 1925 but this is all about
the opportunity to serve all the people
around the world is that incredible so
that's what we went back to didn't it
wasn't talking about Jaguar and Aston
Martin and Land Rover he was talking
about Ford so we went to work and we did
all those things that you just said we
focused on the Ford brand we decided
have a complete family of vehicles small
medium and large cars utilities and
trucks in every region around the world
we also decided that they'd be best in
class in quality and fuel efficiency
safety really smart design like sync and
MyFord and because of our scale in our
intellectual capability running world
absolutely the very best value we also
decided to match our production to the
real demand which is with nothing you
pointed out because we were we were
facilities for market shares was
considerably higher from years back and
so we're unprofitable we also invested
and accelerated our investment and all
these new vehicles during the worst of
times so even though we're losing 17
billion dollars we actually invested
more during the worst of time so we'd be
here to help everybody as part of the
economy recovery the financing we took
out a small home improvement loan we
took this this plan to 500 banks
we've resent it to them we raised 23 and
a half billion dollars bankers don't
want your assets they want you to be
successful that actually like you to pay
the money back not quite as fast as
we're paying it back now because they'd
like to get some interest more interest
to it and then the last thing is we
decided that we're going to work
together as one team for around the
world no matter where we operate we're
gonna operate as one team and use all
that synergy that's why you see the new
c1 platform for the focus you start
going to 10 top hats off that new that
new platform and we could be making 2
million of them worldwide each year in
five different locations and 80% of the
parts are exactly the same all
customized to the unique taste
of the the consumers around the world
you can imagine with with that approach
what we can do visa vie the competition
okay that's my report to the committee
nice job okay now what are you thinking
about and maybe if just we got some
microphones although it's pretty good
here too
and just maybe introduce yourself and
let's let's move to Kuna so many things
to talk about with that especially with
economic development energy independence
and security and environmental
sustainability this will be fun ok all
right let's go to the middle oh dear
let's just say row 18 that want to ask
this question hi there
nico nice to meet you thanks for coming
how do you think about the
sustainability of traffic going forward
and how what is forwards or what is your
vision to to make transport more
sustainable absolutely this is a really
important question and I'm really I'm
just so pleased that the position of
Ford is taken going forward we part of
our business is going to be how do we
have transportation solutions and as you
know we have so many cities now that are
moving into 2 3 4 10 20 million people
in cities and so are going to be part of
that solution about using all modes of
transportation but when you look at the
specifics of your question I think the
technology roadmap we see going forward
which is what we're investing in is
there's a lot of room to improve the
internal combustion engine both petrol
and diesel that's why you see things
like turbo charging and direct fuel
injection lightweight materials
integrated electronics lots opportunity
to improve the new Explorer 30%
improvement in fuel mileage you know all
the capability if you need to carry
seven passengers then I see more
biofuels ethanol cellulosic going
forward
alternative biofuels I think will then
see more electrification always be a
component of natural gas especially for
the bigger vehicles and where you have
the infrastructure for the natural gas
then you'll see more electrification
more hybrids you see plug-in hybrids and
you can see more all-electric but the
real issue there is the infrastructure
and the cost of the batteries because
today you have an all-electric vehicle
the battery alone
fifteen thousand dollars and they waste
seven hundred pounds so it's nice that
you and the battery can ride along in
the car but not anybody else but but
we're working on that really hard and
we're making a lot of progress on it but
it's that part on the technology but
also the infrastructure but I think
electrification we'll see more and more
and then we haven't we're still very
very positive about hydrogen but the
issue there as you know is the when you
have to have the infrastructure again so
it's a public-private partnership
between the governments and business all
around the world on how you want to
proceed but also you need really
efficient fuel cells that are cost
effective which we don't have today and
you still need the very efficient
battery because you're going to take
hydrogen mix it with platinum out comes
water out the tailpipe and electricity
goes over to the the new capable battery
so kind of the same enabling technology
box or needed for all of them but it's
kind of that progression that we see
going forward I think the biggest thing
is that we we the citizens of the world
are going to play a very important part
and make a decision about where we go
what do we want to do about energy
independence and security right what are
we going to do about generating our
electricity clean because can't just be
working on using it clean but we need to
generate a claim and then where do we
want to go with energy policy going
forward on the sustainability of kind of
another neat thing eighty percent of all
the Ford vehicle components are we
recycle so we have very quietly moved to
a place where you really do want to use
the minimum amount of resources the
minimum amount of time yes sir hi my
name is Alex thank you so much for being
here today I'm actually a joint MBA and
master's in public policy student and I
see Ford as basically a great example
almost symbolizing this country coming
out of our recession here on the one
hand a remarkable turnaround story 6.6
billion in profit last year sales are up
companies can't go on the company is
looking great for the future on the
other hand there's still very high
unemployment and employment for Ford as
you know have made some tough decisions
which are absolutely necessary and the
country in some ways has corporate
profitability its highest level ever
last year
but other parts of the economy that
aren't doing as well and I'm wondering
where do we go from here do we need to
accept that US manufacturing is going to
look different in the future and and how
do the leading companies how should they
think about operating in this comp in
this country and also nationally
absolutely first of all thank you for
your comments
as the Dean pointed out it's just this
is so important for manufacturing is so
important for the u.s. it's so important
for every country in which we operate
around the world because we are a key
part of the solution for economic growth
right but also energy independence and
security and also environmental
sustainability I I think I mentioned
during our conversation with the Dean
that earlier that when I first when I
first arrived at Ford I was started
working on the public/private
partnerships and going back to
Washington DC I felt like I was running
drugs or guns you know if you're from
the auto industry because they stood so
tall for trying to help under people
understand what the cost benefits were
for both fuel efficiency and safety
because we were putting a lot of costs
and materials and taking them out of
reach of people being able to own them
and I'm so pleased with your comment
that where you started out because we
are now viewed as a major portion of the
solution going forward all those big
issues and going back to the issues that
you raised and we have to talk about it
we have serious problems now you take
our trade deficit and you take our
budget deficit and this is not
sustainable I mean we all have been
living way beyond our means for a lot of
years and we have structural problems
that we absolutely need to address and
it was mentioned that I'm on the
President's Export Council and also we
have a manufacturing subcommittee of
that and I'm just so pleased that we
have now moved the discussion over to
what are we really going to do about the
intersection now of economic development
energy depends and environmental
sustainability because we have to do
this in a public-private partnership and
we're the ones are going to have to vote
we can't do this you can't delegate this
to somebody else these are issues that
we need to decide where we want to take
the US and where do we want to take our
countries all around the world and how
we do that work in working together so
we have a long way to go
yes is now the time to really move those
up on the agenda absolutely I think
there's no reason why the bekkie of
course my the United States why we can't
compete with the best in the world just
like we're doing with manufacturing and
I think it's true for every country
around the world as all the countries
move up Maslow's hierarchy and and
create these great jobs and great
industries it's going to be so
globalized that that operating
everywhere helps everybody and it's not
like I have or have not or zero-sum game
we have to move the economic development
up for everybody right so I think that
the most important thing is you got at
least gotta be competitive in the data
sets you free right you're you're all
business people in the data sets you
absolutely free what is profitable
growth look like there's only two things
you have to do right create products
that people really do want and value and
will actually pay for and do it more
productively than your competition that
means use less resources less time no
need it's taken you two years to get
this degree I think I've contributed to
helping you get through this but I
always go back to that what what are we
here what's our brand what do we stand
for and do we have a profitable growth
plan because if you're not profitably
growing what are you doing you're not
you're going out of business yes sir um
so we've never had a question asker so
close are you okay I'm feeling fine okay
so I want to know what you think about
the the Google car and is it real and
what what's the impact of that do you
know about the Google car
it's one of the dreams of the founders
to have a autonomous car I really like
driving now I say this with with all due
respect because as an airplane person to
you know we've gotten to the place now
where most of our airplanes they can
take off by themselves they can land by
themselves but we always have pilots
there and as an engineer you just can't
anticipate everything there's not
another there's not nothing like the
human being for being able to handle
multiple things and analyze things and
then deal with it and with all of our
engineering skills you just can't
anticipate every situation that
sophisticated vehicles can get
themselves into and so I think that you
there might be specific uses of it but
it'd be very controlled and there's no
reason technically you can't do it
but you can imagine all the different
issues that go along with a system
solution so from Ford we can always have
you in charge and you're going to be the
driver and you're going to be a better
driver because the sink in my for
because you're gonna be able to use
access all your your information your
navigation your guyses control your
hands are going to be on the wheel are
going to use a five position consumer
electronics controller and you're going
to be voice-activated so you can do
everything with your voice you can keep
your eyes on and you're going to be
seamlessly connected to our digital
world you're welcome yes sir I'm sorry
yes I got a mic okay you win
yeah I'm clay Calhoun I'm a second year
student here first I wanted to say I
love my Ford Edge best car I've ever
owned uh in second I I worked a little
with GM during their restructuring and
even more than kind of their balance
sheet what I thought was the main
problem was the institutional culture at
the company which was you know
management versus labor instead of
working together kind of the sense of
entitlement among everyone there and
from what I understand when you got to
Ford things weren't all that different
um can you talk about maybe tell some
stories as to what is like then and what
you did to change the culture um and you
know kind of how you initiate cultural
change from the top down
absolutely Wow
I was thinking that one of the things
that Bill Ford was asked one time about
the culture and I think he used the word
the Kremlin comes to mind from a you
know past history and you can imagine
what it was like at Ford when everybody
was regionalised
there are no skill teams like
engineering manufacturing went across
the company so there's no way to work
together and in everybody scared I mean
it's not going very well we're losing
money there's not that compelling vision
of where we're going they're not actions
in place to get us there so and and
we're having problems with the vehicles
and so it was pretty it was a pretty
tough environment although I'd say that
Ford has always attracted the best and
the brightest through the years from
around the world I mean remember the
whiz kid stories and it's just it's just
a fabulous company with a hundred and
seven year history of innovation
throughout the years and so talented
people motivated people but we didn't
have a plan we didn't have a vision we
didn't have a comprehensive strategy and
we weren't implementing it so it was
pretty scary and everybody's kind of
looking out for themselves and a lot of
people were leaving and so the only
thing I know to do is just like my days
at Boeing was was got to pull everybody
together you need a compelling vision
about where we're going so we all
understand where we're going so then all
the actions are explainable everybody
has to be on the team so I am every
skill team I invited so engineering
manufacturing legal communications every
skill team was now on the team on a
leadership team all reporting to me and
and all the business unit leaders from
around the world Asia Pacific America is
all there and then we started what we do
what I've always done with big airplane
programs as I just have a weekly meeting
where we review everything associated
with the plan everything so we meet at 7
o'clock in the morning cuz we're trying
to honor time changes of Shanghai and in
the Australian or Wilson so we've got
the clocks all up on the wall we're all
internet it connected on the internet we
have screens that we round around table
where we're seeing all the leaders
wherever they are around the world one
set of charts 320 charts all of the plan
whether it's income statement balance
sheet launches the new vehicles it's all
blue bars there's a forecast of red
diamond which is that that leaders
assessment of how it's going then that
there's a risk and opportunities that
all the risk of an identify
the opportunities are then monetized and
so we're looking also five years out so
when we complete the performance like
the six point six or you could also say
an operating profit eight point three I
just might toss that in that everybody
knows what the plan is everybody knows
what the status of the plan is and
everybody knows areas that need special
attention you do it together it mean
goes from seven to about 7:00 to 9:30
and then when we have guests there from
around the world from the engineering
manufacturing all watching then we meet
them and we get their feedback at the
end so you can imagine how how
transparent and and close you get now
when I first started this remember I
told you that that within a couple of
days the forecast was we're going to
lose seventeen billion dollars so I
started the business plan review the
charts are flowing 320 charts
we even have color coded red yellow
green any change on the chart is in blue
so there's lots of doesn't change all
you're looking for is what is changing I
want to hear a long explanation about
what what's going on what you want is
that everybody knows the plan
everybody knows the areas need special
attention so the color got the got the
charts going and I was about three or
four weeks the data is flowing and all
the charts are green and I I stopped and
I said you guys wearing to lose
seventeen billion dollars is there
anything that's not going well I contact
goes to the floor nobody says anything
now I remember that culture you asked
about it wasn't okay to bring things up
I mean was command and control you know
people disappeared
so I think that another week went buying
their green and of course they've got me
they got this new leader
what's this leader going to do and so
the next two weeks later mark fields who
is that a leader of all the Americas
business Canada the United States and
South America had an edge launched in
Oakville Canada and then an actuator
issue on the tailgate so he stopped
production because we're going to be
best in class we're not gonna deliver
one vehicle unless it's done and it's
the best in quality so he had like two
or three thousand edges you know sitting
out on the tundra thank God it was cold
so they weren't sinking in because when
you stop production I mean I mean it's a
big deal and so up comes his chart for
the launch of this new edge and it's
bright red and I mean you it got so
quiet oh you know what they're all
thinking it's over Marc's gone gone he's
out of here and then what's this new guy
going to do so I started to clap now
they knew that was a side the door was
going to open something's going to come
in marks out of here
but I could just I could just feel it I
didn't just and that I said mark is
there anything that we can do to help
you with that and before mark could say
one word Benny Fowler who was a head of
quality now worldwide said mark I think
I've seen that issue on a launch that we
did six months ago because you know the
carbons you have so much product coming
out and that's what's so exciting and
then Joe Hendrix at the time he's the
leader of all age specific now was a
head of a manufacturer and he said
you're gonna need some manufacturing
engineers because as soon as you find
that problem and fix it you're gonna
have to change all those vehicles and
get the production going again I'll have
those I'll have that our dynamite talent
up in Canada immediately and then Derek
Cusack who leads product development
worldwide says mark I've seen that
technical issue on such-and-such five
years ago or something
I'll get right on that that exchange
took 12 seconds 12 seconds we want to
the next chart of course it was Green
one of the next chart it's green the
next week I think it was still red marks
chart everything else is green next week
I think he changed it to yellow because
they found a solution and now they're
implementing it I think the next week it
turned to green and boom all the
vehicles started going and then probably
the one of the most exciting days of my
life both from a oh [ __ ] I mean this is
a terrible situation sorry - my gosh
we're going to make it was the following
week guess what the charts look like
they look like a rainbow like a rainbow
and I'm going oh my goodness I now the
data says right here why we're losing 17
billion dollars because they just set
you free right data tells you everything
but also now it was safe enough
that you could share how it was you
weren't read the issue you're working on
is read in a matter of fact the
expectation is that everybody really
does know what the situation is because
you can't manage a secret people can't
help if you don't know what the real
situation is and it's safe and you're
not going to get killed down you can
imagine the accountability around the
table are you going to be read on an
item then you're going to go through the
week and come back and say to all your
colleagues I was really busy last week I
didn't have a chance to work on that
putting a pressure in a positive way
it's like fantastic because everybody
there is trying to figure out how to
help go forward so on that one day was
probably I was at it was probably like
oh my gosh this is really in bad shape
we all knew that on the other hand I
knew at that moment that we're going to
be able to turn Ford around that's why
okay take one more ok so here's another
one and this thing about vision and and
everybody understanding so I want to
tell you about the first time I drove in
the garage of the world headquarters by
the Ford Motor Company how we doing on
time I'll go in fifth units okay so I'm
left Boeing and I'm coming to Ford Ford
Ford I Drive into the garage or the
world headquarters of Ford Motor Company
and I Drive in there's not one Ford
vehicle in the garage
I know I know and I just left Boeing to
come to Ford and there are all these
aston martins and jaguars and and i'm
everything to myself I wonder what all
the people in this building are working
on I don't think it's Ford and it was it
in Ford was 85 percent of the business
but Ford was kind of and then I remember
walking up and walked in that office I
could share with you and I knew I knew
he right away what we had to do and you
can imagine one the culture change can
you imagine being with all those
different brands we had 97 different
models then we're trying to be
world-class at so let's go work on the
new Jaguar from 8 o'clock to 8 10 then
we'll work on the new edge from a 10 day
20 you imagine doing it for 97 different
things business the days were paid we
will pay you to manage a conglomerate or
over information is ubiquitous people
want to know exactly what that brand
stands for and what to expect when they
walk in that Ford store right and now
they know it's Ford full family small
medium and large cars utility
best-in-class and quality fuel efficient
safety and you could have a laser focus
on that brand so all the suppliers know
what the plan is all your wonderful
customers know what the plan is
so I think what that did to lip - almost
unleash all the talent inside for
because now everybody knew what we're
coming to work for they knew what we're
going to do and then that just created
this you add that with the business plan
review process and the creating value
roadmap where you actually have to
create value every year because it's a
discounted cash flow right it's a
wonderful thing this kind of cash flow
right all you do spill the arrows in the
arrows up in the arrows down and if
you're in business good businesses grow
a discount cash flow whether it's cash
or profits by 15% a year right and most
good companies grow the top line by 7% a
year by making projects people are out
in value and then they also improve your
productivity by 7% and what's 1.07 times
1.07 1.15 that's how you grow 15% a year
that's what good companies do so it's
just it's just absolutely unleashed all
the talent around the world
but if I focus in the vision what we are
having
pensive strategy and then that
relentless implementation part by
working together makes sense yes sir
you're okay one of you learn from it
what would you do Wow
is there another question uh I don't I
don't know about the mistake word I
thought I every time I get you
reflecting about this all the time what
more could you have done win or actions
you could have taken and it was and
there's not anything that I would not do
and I think part the reason is we're in
a crisis right and so you have to you
have to pull together you have to decide
what you're going to do together and
then you got to move decisively and I
don't know how we could have moved any
faster I'm so pleased about how we
pulled together I'll tell you another
thing
I wondered really wondered whether I was
doing the right thing by going back and
testifying on behalf of GM and Chrysler
I mean I'm a market person I really
believe the markets should allocate
precious resources not government's the
market we should do it with our purchase
decision right we're the ones that
decide the products are successful or
companies are gonna be successful and so
to go back and testify on behalf of my
bankrupt competitors I mean it's a
serious question right they were gone
they should have been gone the market
should let it go but I also at the same
time believe like two administrations
and all their economic advisers that if
we would have taken 12 to 15 percent of
the u.s. GDP into bankruptcy
in the United States we would take the
United States from a recession into a
depression so that's why I decide to do
it and if you like to know how to go to
a hearing the most
important thing is a fly on your
corporate jet
works really well I can remind them I
was not there to ask for our precious
taxpayer money I was there supporting my
my competitor for the good of it of the
world and the other thing is it have
very thoughtful answers to their
questions that's another thing remember
when we're we're all sitting there and
they were going down asking Chrysler
would you the leader would you work for
$1 a year if we give you our money
taxpayer money yes please thank you what
did you work for $1 a year yes and
please and then they turn around to Mina
said well mister why would you work for
$1 a year I I just could think of what
the say I kind of rub my chin
thoughtfully and I said no I think I'm
okay where I am
just just got killed for that
when I reminded them but I wasn't there
to ask him for the money but they kind
of forgot about that whatever the other
thing is is they you know you're sitting
there and they give you a little bottles
of water the most important thing is
just a sip because you can't get up and
leave and we're there sometimes like 12
hours and so that's another important
thing is go really easy on the water
because the whole world is watching you
now on a on a really serious note I
think about this all the time
a lot of people asked me because this is
you know it's democracy and it's the way
it works and weren't you offended it the
way you were treated and because you
know they're pretty aggressive questions
it was a serious situation the United
States was slowing down economically
here you had a significant portion of
the GDP was at risk and it's going to
get worse and Hank Paulson who was
secretary of the Treasury was sitting
the same chair that I was in the day
before trying to explain where the $700
went and everybody's scared and they're
anxious and they're asking questions
that need to be asked and so I never
took it I never took it personally and I
also believe the only way to deal with
the with big things like this is you got
to do it together you got to make it
okay just like we're talking about to
have a conversation so I never I don't
have any remorse for that and I I
wouldn't've done that differently I
think everything on the product is good
so I don't think of it so much of
mistakes is that I think that just
pulling together around this compelling
plan and moving decisively that we then
we did at the right time and doing it
fast and it doesn't get any better you
know most people tell you that they wish
they would have done something sooner
not waited I think maybe because we were
in such a terrible crisis we had to move
and and I'm in awe that that we move so
fast and we're now making the best cars
and trucks in the world that people
really do want yes sir
my name is Marcus and thank you for your
time today my questions
vision and so you talked a little about
Ford's globalization yep and a lot of
your competitors have opened up plants
in the United States so my question is
what does it mean to be an American car
manufacturer Wow
it kind of goes back to the question
earlier he and I only kind of speak from
from a multinational large corporation
operates around the world both both
Boeing and with Ford and it really is
about being a global company and you can
have your headquarters somewhere and you
know the taxes and the way you
repatriate money exchange rates and
everything but I really believe that the
companies are going to serve and provide
what people really do want and do it
most effectively are going to be when
that leverage of their assets worldwide
and you know some brands are there's
always that conversation about is
American practice American brands that
help you or not the neat thing about
Ford again is that when Henry set it up
everybody around the world thinks of
their Ford operations at Ford
you know Ford is number one number two
and all the markets in Europe and it in
Ford of Britain is considered to be a
British company and so we're very
fortunate and that's very different than
like you said the companies that have
the say the Asian companies have set
they have come in the United States
because the only reason they did that
was that they were taking all the wealth
back home so there's a lot of
encouragement for them to operate here
too but I love that Ford is in this
place and I think that what we've really
done is accelerate Henry's original
vision actually accelerated by operating
everywhere around the world and it's so
neat to be part of the fabric plus you
know all the customers you know
everything's going on and you're you're
not only providing great cars and trucks
but also great jobs and careers so I
think the big companies that have the
scale in this part of competing are
going to operate like global companies
I uh my name is guy with the mic uh I'm
Chen first year Allen great to have you
here
my question is about I'm trying to do -
Oh me hug
sorry my question is actually about jobs
so dings women point out you cut 40% of
the workforce at Ford and you know I
think it's honor symbol given over
capacity and all the way industry in
general but you know I think so much
about the debate about economic growth
right now is about bringing jobs back
are those jobs coming back absolutely do
you see the auto industry's role in
bringing the jobs absolutely and we just
announced well if I could back up just
little bit to your to your start of your
question because it's really important
this is about business and this is about
profitably growing and you got to do
whatever it takes because if just like
the situation we described you couldn't
go over in many years lose a 17 billion
dollars and then you're gone right so
you have to size yourself to the real
demand no matter what remember in the
automobile industry because all their
costs they thought were fixed then they
would keep their production up over
deliver all these vehicles just to get
the last incremental dollar because they
couldn't didn't think they could do
anything about their cost so what we did
is we went to the to the unions and we
talked about a future where we could
actually make cars in the United States
but we had to have our cost structure
right and we had to size ourselves in
the near term to the lower demand well
we agreed because we came together
around this vision of a properly growing
and actually hiring hiring and providing
great jobs but you got to take the tough
action to get yourself started so you
can keep investing during the toughest
of times so and it's hard I think it's
you don't anybody want to go through
that that's why you this economic
development worldwide is so important
now having said that we size ourselves
to the real demand we took out all the
extra production both as somebody
mentioned earlier also with our
distribution channel and with Ford and
with our suppliers and so now we're
operating profitably at the lower demand
and and we invested for these new
products so now we just announced over
the next two years we're gonna hire
7,000 new employees and just give you
one example we're making the new
Explorer in Chicago that's the one it's
30 percent more efficient than the last
one and we'll be exporting that vehicle
to 94 countries around the world and in
that plan alone will be adding 1,200
jobs and another 600 jobs with 100
suppliers throughout the United States
and all of our suppliers now are all
global
because which when you operate this way
you use your scale globally but then you
operate locally so you get the best of
both both worlds so and our plan is to
fundamentally now to grow the business
year after year forever because that's
that's the purpose of a business so
we're really excited about how everybody
pulled together to get to this place and
now it's really exciting now to grow and
provide all these great opportunities
and asia-pacific we're going is when the
fastest growing companies in
asia-pacific providing tremendous
opportunities great market in Europe a
little bit slower growth little bit more
mature fatwas growth in Brazil Russia
and especially India and China okay well
maybe one last question because I hear
that when it gets close you get up and
leave yeah yeah we got it we got it
okay well um my name is Prakash I was at
the Consumer Electronics Show it laughs
Louis and I got to check out your your
Ford SYNC what do you think and I love
the voice-activated experience but I was
wondering are you guys thinking about a
App Store much like how Apple came out
with theirs for their their hardware
right coming up for an app store for
your hardware we're we're not right now
but you saw the apps that we are
managing now and we also have all the
app producers that are working on what
makes sense for a car the real thing we
decided was was to not get in that as a
business like Apple did but to focus on
the automobile and the safe driving
experience we're not making any money on
all those apps ourselves we could have
taken a piece of each of those like
other business models you know up
because what we what we want to do is
ahead was to make sure that everybody
when they bought a Ford that they could
seamlessly operate and yet be connected
to a digital world
so we're managing that interface that
you saw was sync in my Ford and that's
been our our focus now a lot of people
have wanted us you know when Pandora
comes in or you know the other
applications they would lot of would
like us to do a business with them but
right now we're focused on providing a
better driving experience and a safer
experience but having all of us be I
have access to the internet for right
now yes
thanks again for joining us and I
appreciate getting to ask the last
question my name is
Caroline Mullin I'm a first year here
and I had the honor while I was at
deutsche bank before Stanford of working
with the Ford Credit team oh very good
and I wanted to know what you thought
their role was in the turnaround of Ford
in 2009 and they're active kind of
intensive balance sheet management and
then what your objectives are for
balance sheet management as you're
positioning for growth but also
preparing for another potential crisis
fantastic it sound like had a great
experience of the bank - they're there
they're one of our main bankers - and
they're fantastic what what she is
referring to is what we call a Ford
Motor Credit Corporation and it's a
captive finance company that we have
meaning that we own it and its cost of
capital goes with the parent with Ford
as opposed to you know an independent
bank this has been really important for
Ford because as you go through these
cycles that let's say your banker
friends kind of come and go a little bit
and I mean because they're managing
their life - but but the reason we have
a Ford Credit Corporation is that during
the worst of times the best of times
then we can continue to help with the
financing for that all of our Ford store
owners with all their inventory all the
vehicles we also have wind stop shopping
so when you walk into a Ford store you
can get your financing for the vehicle
in addition to the vehicle and remember
when we went through this crisis GM I'm
there in such there trying to work the
cash so carefully they actually sold
GMAC which they was their captive
finance company so we really believe
we've done the right thing it really
helped us get through this right now we
have scaled back for credit with the
divestiture of all these other brands
but now they're really right size and
they're just an absolute key part of our
business going forward and I'm just so
pleased that we kept that as a priority
to keep that captive finance coming and
now on our balance sheet now guess just
gets better and better you saw last year
that you know when you borrow twenty
three and a half billion dollars you
need to pay it back and and it's a
wonderful thing to be paying back our
and our goal of course one goal is is to
move back to investment grade because in
our cost of capital comes down that
makes that allows us to invest more in
the products but also allows Ford credit
to be even more competitive on helping
you with loans so last year we paid
fourteen and a half billion dollars back
on our loans which is fantastic and
we'll probably keep some debt because
it's good to leverage a little bit but
we're clearly moving back to investment
grade a lot faster than what everybody
thought and the most important thing is
you're growing the business profitably
generating free cash flow because it
gives you great options not only on
improving the balance sheet but also on
the products okay I know you're going to
get up and leave and I would take it
personally if I wasn't done so I'm going
to be done I was honored to get a
request to come here I grew up in Kansas
I grew up in Seattle with Boeing we've
had tremendous programs with Stanford
over the years it's a fabulous school as
you know you're getting when the finest
education is and you also get one of the
best global education so it's so
important for where the world's going
and so thank you for the invitation and
congratulations to you I look forward to
working with you I would love you to
consider maybe Ford as you're
considering going forward and also maybe
you should drive a Ford and feel a
difference
grateful
a fool